okay so I just saw Logan it oh that's
right folks
Doctor Who series 10 trailer is out and
I have seen it got some thoughts as is
often the case with me and Doctor Who
series trailers there general thoughts
cuz we're only getting general bits for
getting little tiny snippets here's a
glimpse of this who's a glimpse of that
a lot of which was stuff that had been
announced in some degree or another
before but you know I love Doctor Who so
I'm gonna take any excuse I can to talk
about the thing okay so starting out
first voice be here is Capaldi's which
is 95y what the emphasis on him as much
as possible it's his last season we're
gonna get out of him I want him at his
best and just hearing his voice always
makes me smile so be a little bit of
Nardo then we get bills showing up and
her first time in the TARDIS and we see
an interaction between her and the
doctor that made me go oh dear she says
it's like any job since as a spaceship
and then she said something I know I
don't know what in the doctor goes what
and that was exactly what I was thinking
but what I swear to God I backed up that
part of it ten times I have no clue what
she says I'm worried I'm gonna have to
watch this thing with subtitles on which
I've had to do in the past
on occasion like especially when Clara
was on the show because he had really
fast talking companion with a fast
talking doctor sometimes ah and so the
next few bits we see after that kind of
largely focus on Bill and her reactions
to new things that she's seeing and
they're not bad they're not unpleasant I
kind of feel like I've seen him before
they feel a little bit like Rose a
little bit like Amy she's got a slightly
different energy and a different vibe
and hopefully that'll be enough to
differentiate her from the other sort of
street-smart kind of companions I will
say though narwhals the one reaction we
got from him cuz bill had like several
on a row and she's like it's speaks
mojin emoji and she's not like here and
then Gnarls just surrounded by spears he
goes slice here in there like that I
love that I
that much more and again I'm really
trying to not be prejudiced against bill
I would like I would like to enjoy her
but I'm digging nardole so much I just
hope that she doesn't it doesn't feel
like she's dragging him down
now the next thing they have I am gonna
assume this is two different things cut
together but I liked it the bill has the
line how do we see out of trouble in the
docs the doctors was just this grin it's
just this grin that says oh that's not
how I do it we get that glimpse of that
girl who looked like she was forming
like almost like some sort of reverse
water splash like inward thing and she
goes exterminate and I'm immediately
intrigued by that because I the Daleks
unfortunately the last few sees that
series have have started to feel a bit
like fodder the last Dalek story that I
really enjoyed that was a pure Dalek
story as opposed to a Davros story which
they're not quite the same thing for me
was asylum of the Daleks but since that
one their appearances have not been
great for me but this intrigues me I'm
hoping it's an indication of something
new and interesting that the Daleks are
up to and that's the point that the
trailer just kicks up and you know the
harder beat comes in we get rapid cuts
we get looks at monsters these creepy
things with like these long hands and
there's kind of these rotted faces thing
going on we get a like I'm real like
half second glimpse of a Mondas Cybermen
I didn't make a video I wasn't I wasn't
feeling up for it when the announcement
was that the Mondas Cybermen complete
would like the stocking cap faces are
coming back and I'll sort of take the
opportunity to talk about that a little
bit I'm really intrigued by that because
the Cybermen can be very good but
they're really easy to mess up and I
think even going back into the classic
era a lot of the uses of the Cybermen
didn't really work for me the best
Cybermen story is still tombs of the
Cybermen which is a second doctor
adventure and I know it had been Neil
Gaiman's intention that the sort of
latest revision we got on the Cybermen
that redesigned the idea was that the
Mondas Cybermen met up with the cyber
Cybermen which were introduced in
tenants runned the ones from the
alternate universe and they sort of
merged together to form this new thing
now that wasn't
but it doesn't ever appear in the
episode itself so I don't think it's
considered canon so we're now getting
original montes era Cybermen and even
beyond that though I figure this has got
to be it's gonna be a bit like tombs of
the Cybermen think these are guys who
must have been isolated because even
those Mondas Cybermen were upgrading
themselves into different looks over
time even back in the classic era cos
that they all sort of spawned and you
know they kept upgrading themselves so
these look like the original original
then either we're travelling back in
time to when they had not upgraded from
that original design or this is a sort
of a pocket of them that for whatever
reason has been existing in isolation
for a while I'll be really interested to
see it and I hope it can be as creepy as
those are you guys I mean the the
adventure that actually appeared in
looking like that which was the 10th
planet I'm pretty sure is one of the
Lost episodes there are tiny clips of it
there are bits but the entirety of it
has not been found or recovered yet but
if you've ever seen clips of those those
Cybermen and they just sort of and they
just open their mouths and they don't
move but they just the mouth holds up
and then the robotic voice comes out
it's that's creepy so I'm down for that
there was also a really quick glimpse of
an Ice Warrior which I maybe I hadn't
been paying enough attention I didn't
know the Ice Warriors were coming back
again which I'm kind of up and down on I
actually liked the episodes cold war
better than most people I think but I
didn't love it and I'm not sure what
else there is to do with the Ice
Warriors but you know if they've got an
idea I'm open to it we got our glimpse
of Missy again I know not everyone likes
her I love Missy I love her a lot and
just that you a bunch of little moments
of Oh things just got real like the
robot that had the thumbs up for eyes
now it's got skulls fries and you know
just little things it's it's it's well
pasted we get glimpses of things that
are interesting we get almost no sense
of story which is fine by me
tagline at the end the time for Heroes
it's kind of kind of lame it's kind of
generic I'm assuming somebody just threw
that together like we really need a line
at the end when they're all like running
slow or there's me uh time for Heroes
that's not good
we're on deadline
put it up that's what it feels like a
little bit but I am excited for this
series and I'm really I want Capaldi to
go out on a high note because his time
he is he has had he has given wonderful
performance almost from the beginning
but he has had a couple of really
phenomenal episodes but the consistency
of these series hasn't been the best and
when they have gone bad we've gotten
stuff like Sleep No More and in the
forest of the night which you can't not
what I hate as much as other people but
I still recognize it's not good and then
of course hell-bent but you want to talk
about a divisive thing oh yeah but I'm
really just hoping that with Clara gone
we can get a clearer focus on him
because they really did feel like she
was taking over the narrative for a
while there and I want to close out on
him with a good time and as far as you
know glimpses that I can't actually
discern any story from this gets me
excited so it does what a trailer is
supposed to do so the series 10 Doctor
Who trailer have you seen it what are
your thoughts on it whatever they are
drop something down in the comment let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher
I promise I will bring the green screen
back when the actual episodes start
happening yeah I'm in the element
Vermont I'm in the middle of the
snowstorm the wind is howling where I
have the green screen set up it's too
darn noisy but for right now this
council is adjourned
[Applause]